ومن تويتر الى منصه المحادثه الجديده التي
تعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي
والتي اطلقتها شركه اوبن اي اي اواخر
العام الماضي المنصه اصبحت موضوع الحديث
الاول في عالم التكنولوجيا المعلومات بسبب
قدرتها على تاليف الخطب وروايه القصص في
ثواني معدوده وبدقه بالغه اعتمادا على
الذكاء الاصطناعي لكن هذه المنصه التي تمت
تغذيتها بكميات ضخمه من البيانات ليست
مثيره للاعجاب فقط وانما للشكوك ايضا حيث
اشار علماء وخبراء التكنولوجيا المعلومات
الى اربع ثغرات اساسيه في نظام
اولها امكانيه التلاعب في حيث يعتمد نظام
على مجموعه واسعه للغايه من التطبيقات اما
الثغره الثانيه فتتمثل في صعوبه تتبع
مصادر المعلومات او المحتوى في النظام
المشكله الثالثه تتمثل في المخاوف
المتعلقه بحمايه الخصوصيه حيث تظل المخاوف
بشان تامين البيانات وحمايتها في كل تقنيه
جديده اما المشكله الرابعه فاتت تمثل في
ان نظام المنصه ما زال غير ناضج وفي مرحله
التطور